الشباب راحوا ضحيه مين قولوي يا ناس
عرفوني ضحيه مين اح يا شعب يا دول العربيه
اسمعيني يا دول العربيه يا ربي صوتي كلهم
يسمعوه صوتي يل الدول اللي قاعده وبتاكل
وبتشرب ولادها بيناموا يصحوا احنا دمنا من
دمكم اصحوا قوموا
اتحركوا احنا بنموت احنا شعبنا بموت حرام
عليكم اتقوا الله فينا يا ناس انا بقول
لكم اتقوا الله فينا الحسد يصير فيكم زي
ما صار فينا اتخيلوا يمكن يوم يجيكم انتم
يصير فيكم
زينا حسوا فينا حسوا في امهاتكم في بناتكم
احنا عاركم
وشرفكم يناموا في الشوارع اتقوا الله انا
من حرقه قلبي بعيط على الشباب اللي راحت
احلى
شباب احلى شباب
استجدت خفتت دار
تسع طوابق ست طوابق تهيل 90 نفر 50 نفر
ليش ايش عاملين احنا ايش عاملين يا الله
اتقوا فينا يا الله اكثر من هيك انا مش
قادره احكي اتقوا الله وحسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل على كل واحد ما بده يجف معنا ويحكي
كلمه خير ويوقف الحرب لا احنا
استوينا عن جد استوينا خلص ما ضلش فينا لا
دم ولا لحم
ا